let's see who else is holding on here
let's go over to the two one five area
code caller from two one five who's this
hi David this is Evan from Pennsylvania
hey what's going on Evan nothing much I
have a question I wanted to pick your
brain a little bit about automation so
this is kind of worrying me because you
know I'm in college right now and a lot
of my friends are getting jobs to kind
of help pay for food and stuff like that
you know lower end jobs those are
increasingly becoming automated and now
the higher end jobs with advancements in
hey I are they might become automated so
with that many people will probably not
be making money and in a capitalist
system this might apps our economy and
do some real damage so I wanted to ask
do you prefer stopping or heavily
regulating automation and provide okay
isn't cut out you just cut out there
after asking me if I want to regulate
automation what was the second part of
the question
oh and by tax cuts to employers through
employment and don't all right your your
cell phone service is going in and out
so I think I've got the question I'll do
my best to answer it so I think that the
there is an inevitability to automation
that is just it's just a real thing it's
happening okay so I don't think that
efforts to prevent automation are
particularly good places to put time
money energy effort call it what you
will I think it's going to happen the
important conversation that we have to
have is one that is much more difficult
than tax cuts for employers that don't
automate or restrictions on technology
the real conversation we have to have in
the economic system that we we have in
the United States
in many countries is we need to
reevaluate
the relationship between work and humans
Homo sapiens and humans they're in a
capitalist system there's a certain
relationship there which is basically
your worth is determined by the job that
you do and how much money you make and
as automation continues to grow that is
just not going to be a good way it was
never a good way I should say of
assessing people's worth the society but
it's gonna be a particularly poor way so
universal basic income guaranteed jobs
programs restructuring the economy in
other ways revaluing assigning economic
value to intangibles like art and music
and exploration investigation stuff like
that that's the real serious
conversation that has to be had it's a
much more difficult one then let's tax
robots for example and that's the one
that I've seen no willingness for any
national politicians really to have and
I don't totally blame them for their
lack of willingness because there's no
upside to that right when you're running
a campaign you've got to say
I'll bring manufacturing jobs back and
then your opponent says no I'm going to
bring them back the real conversation
right is a lot of those jobs are not
coming back they don't exist anymore and
more are going to go out of existence
let's deal with that but there's really
no political upside to doing that so
you're more for like kind of like
economic rewiring of relationship all
right absolutely cool thank you for the
call appreciate it great to hear from
you